sur les routes ce matin le trafic était
fluide même très fluide sur l'ensemble
des grands axes du département
tout le monde est sûrement partie plus
tôt mais là bas comme vous le voyez la
personne sur la route
selon la carte en temps réel publié par
citadin à 9 heures seulement 50
kilomètres de bouchons étaient recensés
sur la région contre plus de 300 à 400
km à la même heure habituellement jamais
en voiture pour être sûr de ne pas être
coincé enfin tout en attendant à la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines à montigny
le bretonneux seulement sept trains
circulaient entre 6 heures et 9 heures
en direction de paris
les usagers se sont organisés je devais
aller à l'école argenteuil ne faut pas y
aller théâtre au degré pour les trains
face à cette grève certains yvelinois
ont opté pour des solutions de
substitution
j'avais en fait prendre d abord le bus
après je vais rejoindre une collègue on
va faire tu qu'on va dire âge jusqu'à la
défense le parking de la gare de la
verrière habituellement bondées est
presque désert peu d'usagers sont venus
aujourd'hui à la gare de la verrière
aucun train ne circulait j'étais si
depuis 5 heures du matin pour prendre le
train pour aller à
les montparnasse mais ya pas de train
dehors il fait tellement froid moins 1
degré dans ses cordes
je dois aller jusqu à châtillon non non
je prends la ligne n
après le monsieur tous les bus sont
complets et il est plus trop monter les
gens donc je ne sais pas malgré les
difficultés rencontrées certains
yvelinois soutiennent cette grève je
soutiens parce que je trouve que c'est
très important ce qu'ils entendent le
faire même pour eux et vie pour non plus
tard aussi donc voila et pour nos
enfants aussi je suis favorable à la
grève mais vu que vu que ces invocations
à la fille du coup je suis venu je
soutiens le mouvement c'est normal les
autres personnes ils vont partir
peut-être à 67 ans à la retraite
donc il faut que ça dure ça ça va mal
finir les voyageurs qui ont rencontré
des obstacles sur leur parcours habituel
se renseigne pour les perturbations à
prévoir de demain j'ai pris donc les
précautions davance j'ai posé une
journée de rtt
je suis à la gare pour la journée de
demain surtout parce que bon on pense
que ça va ça va se décanter un tout
petit peu et puis nous permettent
d'aller travailler c'est tout ce que moi
tout ce que je veux c'est être à mon
poste de travail quoi des assemblées
générales de grévistes se sont tenues
aujourd'hui à la ratp le syndicat unsa
qui est majoritaire annonce que les
salariés se sont prononcés sur une
reconduite de la grève jusqu'à lundi
inclus